[Music]
major new fallout from that epic Best
Picture mix-up at the Oscars the
question is who's got the key
we both have a key to this ET is
confirmed that accountants Brian
Cullinan and Martha Ruiz will not be
returning to the Oscars after Sunday
night's Best Picture flop
there's a mistake moonlight you guys won
Best Picture
the duo from PricewaterhouseCoopers
walked the red carpet each carrying a
set of winners envelopes Cullinan has
been under fire after it was revealed he
handed presenter Warren Beatty the wrong
envelope it was the backup for actress
in a leading role Academy president
Cheryl Boone Isaacs said today the error
was caused because Cullinan was
distracted in fact just three minutes
before Best Picture was announced
Cullinan tweeted this photo of Emma
Stone backstage today several photos of
emerge of Culloden backstage just before
the blunder this image was snapped of
him on his phone at 9:04 p.m. just
moments after the backstage envelope
mix-up
although Cullinan and Ruiz will no
longer work with the Academy we have
learned they will remain as partners at
their accounting firm Cullinan has not
commented since the incident his wife
however was snapped out shopping with a
bodyguard
today meanwhile the Academy says its
relationship with PricewaterhouseCoopers
remains under review now the Academy
also apologized for showing the wrong
person when they remembered costume
designer Janet Patterson